- I'm Ron DeSantis and
I'm running for president
to lead our great American comeback.
(intense music continues)
- [Narrator] Florida
governor, Ron DeSantis,
has officially entered the
2024 presidential race,
after announcing his bid
in a Twitter conversation
with Elon Musk.
- [Ron] Governing is not entertainment.
It's not about building a
brand or virtue signaling.
It is about delivering results.
And our results in Florida
have been second-to-none.
We can and we must deliver
big results for America.
- [Narrator] After a
big win in the midterms
and a successful legislative
session in Florida,
DeSantis is looking to
take his politics national,
going head to head with
former president Donald Trump
for the GOP nomination.
- They are the top two contenders
for the Republican
nomination at this point.
No one else comes close.
- [Narrator] But moving
from state politics
to a national stage
presents its own challenges for DeSantis.
So what should we expect
from the governor,
and what challenges lie ahead?
(somber music)
Once close allies,
the relationship between
DeSantis and Trump
has evolved greatly over time.
- We need to elect Ron DeSantis
as your governor.
(crowd cheering)
- [Narrator] Trump endorsed DeSantis
in the 2018 gubernatorial election.
- Mr. President, I look
forward to working with you
to advance Florida's priorities.
I think you're gonna get
tired of me calling you,
asking you for things for Florida.
- They felt similarly on a lot of issues.
DeSantis sort of championed
those issues back in Florida.
The president had a real ally there.
That really came off the wheels recently
as the governor asserted
himself politically
and began to look at a presidential run.
- [Narrator] Now, Trump's
attitude toward DeSantis
has soured, often jabbing the governor
about sagging approval ratings.
- Let's see, there it is, Trump at 71,
Ron DeSanctimonious at 10%.
- He feels that the governor is disloyal,
that Ron DeSantis is not
showing him proper respect
by challenging him for the presidency.
- [Narrator] DeSantis has
largely avoided responding
to the former president's attacks.
- I don't know how to
spell DeSanctimonious.
I don't really know what it means,
but you know, I kinda like it.
It's long, it's got a lotta vowels.
I mean, so.
(Piers laughing)
We can go with that, that's fine.
You know, you can call
me whatever you want.
I mean, just as long as you, you know,
also call me a winner.
- In order to win the
Republican nomination,
Ron DeSantis is going to need
a lot of Trump supporters.
So alienating those with
hard-hitting attacks
against the former president
could turn those people off.
- Donald Trump.
- [Narrator] Since
winning the 2018 election,
DeSantis' popularity among
voters has exploded in Florida,
illustrated by his landslide
19-point reelection win
in the November midterms.
And his popularity continued to grow
after he delivered several
conservative policy victories
during the last legislative
session in Florida.
From restrictions on drag shows
to limiting spending on
diversity programs in colleges,
DeSantis' policies have
made national headlines
and will likely serve as the backbone
for his presidential campaign
as he tries to win over
a wider range of voters.
- He'll be able to say,
"Look how effective I was.
I got X, Y, and X done."
Versus, you know, some of the struggles
that Trump as president had
getting his agenda passed.
- [Narrator] Other bills
endorsed by DeSantis
include allowing concealed
handguns without a permit
and a strick six-week abortion ban.
While those policies
may serve DeSantis well
in the primaries, they could also prove
to be a challenge for him
in the general election.
In a "Wall Street Journal" poll
asking about the right to
carry a concealed handgun
without a permit,
56% of Republican primary voters
said they support that right.
While nationwide, 65% of overall
voters were in opposition.
And for the six-week abortion ban,
68% of Republican primary
voters favored the ban,
but 53% of voters overall opposed it.
- The abortion issue is very complex.
It's controversial.
Six weeks is seen as pretty
extreme by a lot of people.
- [Narrator] DeSantis is also preparing
to challenge the incumbent
president, Joe Biden,
who along with Trump
has experience running
in presidential elections
and winning them.
- DeSantis is not tested
on a national stage.
He doesn't have the experience dealing
with world leaders or major global issues.
So that'll be something
that both Trump and Biden
would use against Ron DeSantis.
- [Narrator] DeSantis
now joins a growing swath
of Republican candidates in the race,
including Trump, former
South Carolina governor,
Nikki Haley, and South
Carolina senator, Tim Scott,
with the potential for others,
including former vice
president Mike Pence,
who may announce in the coming months.
- Right now, it's down to
Donald Trump and Ron DeSantis.
It's their fight to lose.
Republicans are hungry for someone
who can get something done.
There's a number of other Republicans
that are vying for this and
they're gonna be looking
especially to see if
Ron DeSantis stumbles.
Essentially, if you boil down
Ron DeSantis' argument is,
"I am effective.
I can carry on the agenda that
Donald Trump kinda started
but actually get it passed."
(light music continues)